[Musique]
la sixième édition de la journée de la
production agricole réunionnaise s'est
tenue à la petite île l'occasion pour la
commune de présenter son pays où est né
son périmètre de protection et de mise
en valeur des espaces agricoles et
naturels périurbains
nous avons plusieurs outils de
planification le schéma d'aménagement
régional nous avons les schémas de
cohérence cohérence territoriale l'épée
élus mais eux souvent c'est le monde
urbain qui a dicté à la ruralité la
politique d'aménagement nous voulons
inverser cette tendance et dire que
c'est la ruralité qui demain va limiter
l'extension urbaine et c'est la réalité
qui va devoir dessiner je dirais la
réunion puisque les paysages lattes et
culture les espaces naturels c'est ce
qui fait aussi la valeur de notre
territoire territoire grande vocation
touristique un dispositif qui vise donc
à préserver les espaces agricoles et
naturels menacées par l'urbanisation la
direction de l'agriculture au
département a présenté le travail mené
auprès des filières pour la création
d'un label de produits locaux 100%
réunion au le 100 % local c'est bien sûr
le produit le légume qu'on produit à la
réunion 100% local mais après moi je
veux regarder derrière notamment dans
les unités de transformation
est-ce qu'on havre et à blanc dans le
produit qui sera proposée aux
consommateurs
est ce que tous les ingrédients on
retrouve dans ce produit est ce qu'il
est d'origine réunion et là il va y
avoir des curseurs et on va bien sûr à
voir le verre par exemple 100% local sur
90 81 50 20 peut-être y aura qu'un petit
peu de produits de la réunion dans dans
une boîte proposé mais le consommateur
il sera informé du sens qu'on donne au
label produit réunion les invités ont
également débattu de la place des
produits locaux dans la restauration
collective est du lancement de la 30e
édition de la fête de l'ail
[Musique]